hello grammarians and hello Paige hi
David today we're going to be talking
about commas in correspondence and what
that means is is how to use commas in
letter writing uh so saying hello and
saying goodbye when you start writing a
letter or an email to somebody you use
commas
um so let me let me show you an example
so if you're writing a letter to someone
you open it with something like this
Dear Prudence comma I received the plum
jam you sent me and you can see we have
this little comma here
because what commas do right is they
separate elements of the sentence from
one another
so what we're doing here with this comma
is we're putting it after the greeting
to separate it from the body text so
that's how you begin a letter or an
email with a comma after the you know
deer part or the hello Prudence comma
part you know whatever it is but Paige
how do you use commas toward the end of
of Correspondence of emails and stuff
right so at the end of a letter or an
email
uh you'll use a comma in a sort of
similar way to how you use it at the
beginning so you'll say something like
with love
comma
Bruce Ben Bacharach
so okay so we can we can use them at the
beginning like this
Dear Prudence comma or we can use it at
the end
of the endings of letters so so this has
a technical name we were discussing this
before we started recording so if you if
you open a letter
um that's called the salutation which is
another way to say hi
uh and the way you end a letter is
called a valediction
which is like a
saying hail I think Wale in Latin means
hail I think salute is hello and Wale or
Vale is goodbye and so this is really
just like a hello winning and a goodbye
saying so if you're saying hello in a
letter or an email you use a comma if
you're saying goodbye in a letter or an
email
use a comma you can learn anything David
out page out